بعد ان وصلت المحادثات الى طريق مسدود بين
الطرفين وبعد هدنه بسيطه في وقت الافطار
العاصمه الخرطوم شهدت انقطاعا في التيار
الكهربائي كما تجددت الاشتباكات سريعا مع
اعلان كل طرف تحقيق تقدمات على الارض مجلس
السياده السودانيه اكد ان معظم المنشات
العسكريه والحيويه هي تحت سيطره الجيش كما
اكدت رئاسه اركان الجيش السوداني انه لا
حوار او تفاهمات قبل انهاء تفلتات الدعم
السريع مصادر في الجيش اضافت ان مجهودات
الرباعيه الدوليه مقدره لكن ما يحدث هو
تمرد يجب ان يتم اخماده فيما اكد قائد
الدعم السريع للعربيه انه لا يزال يدير
العمليات من الخرطوم ووسط كل هذا تدعو
معظم دول العالم رعاياها الى الالتزام
باماكنها وعدم الخروج في المناطق المفتوحه
خصوصا بعد ان علقت معظم شركات الط يران
العالميه رحلتها الى الخرطوم بشكل مؤقت
حتى تتكشف نتائج ما يحدث اليوم
السيطره تامه على مطار الجنان الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر على مطار الله اكبر الحمد لله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
يا شباب منورين وفي اخر الجهود الدوليه
لحل الازمه قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه
ان وزراء خارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان والامارات الشيخ عبد الله بن زايد
ال نهيان والامريكيه انتون بلينكن ناقشوا
الموقف الحالي في السودان خلال اتصال
هاتفي مشترك واكد وزراء وخارجيه السعوديه
والامارات وامريكا على اهميه وقف التصعيد
العسكري في السودان وضروره العوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان
من جهته دعوه وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
جيمس كليفر للقياده السودانيه لوقف
التصعيد والتحكم بقواتها وغرد كلافر عبر
تويتر ان العنف يجب ان يتوقف لمنع سفك
المزيد من الدماء وان الحل العسكري لن يحل
الموقف
عدد من القتلى والمصابين من المدنيين
سقطوا في الاشتباكات الجاريه اليوم وفق
لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه اللجنه ناشدت
اطراف النزاع بوقف الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
ومدن سودانيه عده وفتح مسار للمصابين
لتلقي الخدمات الصحيه وكانت العربيه وثقت
اصابات لمدنيين بعد ان علقوا وسط النيران
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في منطقه بحر في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
والخارجيه السودانيه تقول الان توغل لقوات
من الدعم السريع في مطار الخرطوم تسبب
بتضرر طائرتين اذن حسب الخارجيه
السودانيات تؤكد بانه توغل قوات من الدعم
السريع في مطار الخرطوم تسبب بتضرر
طائرتين وايضا الهجوم على مطار الخرطوم
تسبب باضرار بطائره سعوديه واخرى سودانيه
اذا تؤكد الخارجيه السودانيه بان الهجوم
على مطار الخرطوم تسبب بتضرر لطائره
سعوديه واخرى سودانيه قال رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي في السودان الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان في تصريحات للعربيه ان
المتمردين من قوات الدعم السريع ساعه
للسيطره على مقرات الجيش والمناطق الحيويه
فجرا واضاف البرهان ان متمردي الدعم
السريع خطته لتنفيذ اغتيالات وان خيار
الجيش الوحيد هو التصدي لمطامع من وصفهم
بالمتمردين في السلطه وقال عبد الفتاح
البرهان ان الجيش يدير عمليات ضد
المتمردين بصبر لمنع وقوع اي خسائر بشريه
مؤكدا ان الجيش السوداني لديه قوات كافيه
واراده لدحر هؤلاء الاشخاص
الخارجيه السودانيه تتحدث ايضا ان الجيش
استعاد السيطره على مطار الخرطوم اذا
الخارجيه السودانيه تتحدث عن ان الجيش
استعاد السيطره على مطار الخرطوم
نشد عضو مجلس السياده الانتقالي في
السودان مالك عقار الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع بوقف المعارك الدائره بينهما على
الفور والاحتكام الى صوت العقل واضاف عقار
ان لجنه الوساطه ستواصل السعي من اجل
تحقيق وقف فوري لاطلاق النار من ثم معالجه
المشكلات التي ادت لوقوعه مؤكدا ان ما
يحدث هو امر كارثي وكان يمكن تجنبه لو
التزمت كافه الاطراف بالروح الوطنيه على
حد تعبيره
الان طيران
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر يا شباب منورين ده
مطار الجنينه يا جماعه ده مطار الجنينه
احتلينا احتلال كامل شامل من الجيش ولا
همزات
من الخرطوم ينضم الى مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا الوضع لديك في
هذه الاثناء
نعم الاوضاع هنا
في هذه الى حد
ما نسبيا بشكل
طبيعي لكن ليس بشكل كامل هناك في
الخرطوم تجددت الاشتباكات مره اخرى
في منطقه محيط القياده العامه للجيش في
الخرطوم وكذلك للمناطق في ام درمان متفرقه
ايضا المناطق التي تجددت فيها الصراع لكن
غالب هذه شمال ام درمان منطقه كوبري
الحلفايه السنه الحربي والمدرعات ومن ثم
الكليه الحربيه ايضا تجددت الاشتباكات في
بالقرب
ان ننتقل لنتابع هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
الان على شاشه العربيه
للسيد عبد الفتاح البرهان
متواجد مع العسكريين في احد المناطق نستمع
الى صوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
اذا نتابع هذه الصور لرئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه تجول في مناطق بالعاصمه الخرطوم
وبعض العسكريين متواجدين ايضا حوله نستمع
الى صوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا رئيس المجلس السيادي
عبد الفتاح البرهان يتجول في عده مناطق
الخرطومه كما يتفقد بعض المواقع العسكريه
اعود الى زميلنا سالم الهاشمي سالم نعود
اليك لتطلعنا على تطورات الحاصله خاصه في
المناطق التي تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه في هذه
الاثناء
تسمع الاصوات حتى هذه اللحظه حتى قبل
اللحظات الاصوات اليدويه المدافع
ايضا
اطلاق النار بكثافه في هذه المناطق
وهذا الامر مستمر من قبل الافطار لكن بعد
الافطار وتيره
زادت هذه الوثيره بشكل ملفت الانتباه ايضا
ننوه لانه ايضا رئاسه اركان القوات
المسلحه قد اكدت انها لا تفاوض ولن تحاول
قبل ان تحل وتفتك ميليشيا حماتي المتمرده
اكدت هذا المعنى وهذا يدل على زياده
الوتيره وانه لا يكون هناك حل في وقت قريب
هذا الامر واضح جدا من هذه التصريحات ايضا
عموما السياده الهادي ادريس قد ذكره بانه
يدعو الجيش والدعم السريع لوقت الا تجيب
البلاد شره الانهيار الشامل وايضا بان
البلاد تمر في لحظه مفصليه من تاريخ
عقلانيه فقال هذه الحرب لم ينتصر فيها حدث
تخسر السودان للابد ونشر الدوليه للمساعده
عاجله في وقت المواجهه الدمويه
ايضا الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
اكد ان الموقف مستقر وان الجيش يعمل
بعزيمه لاعاده الامن والاستقرار وذكر انهم
ما كانوا يريدون تنحدر الاوضاع بحد توجيه
السودانيين سلاحهم بوجه بعض لهذه الطريقه
المؤسفه عضو مجلس السياده ايضا الفريق
ياسر العظمه ذكر
في تصريحات خاصه بالعربيه بان
رحمته يخطط منذ فتره طويله لان يكون الرجل
الاول وانه يحاول انطفاء ظهر حصان قوى
لتحقيق هدفه بحكم السودان وقال ان نتابع
تحركات الرجل ونعلم ان صاحب الصفر اقتربت
صباح اليوم حاولتي الخروج بقوات كبيره من
جنوب الخروج مع هجوم على
منزلنا نستمع الى صوت النيران حيث الصوره
المباشره من الخرطوم للعربيه
اذا نستمع مشاهدينا هذه الصوره من الخرطوم
نستمع فيها لاطلاق قذائف وايضا هناك ذوية
لاطلاق نيران
[موسيقى]
سالم اطلاق النار الكثيف هذا اين يتركز في
اي مناطق حول اي مواقع
هذه المنطقه هي في قلب العظم الخرطوم
بالقرب من مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني وبالقرب ايضا من مطار الخرطوم
وهذه القرب وهي المنطقه المركزيه في قلب
العاصمه المطار الخرطوم وقياده للجيش
السوداني وحتى مقر الدعم السريع الذي حرق
نهار اليوم في هذه الاشتباكات قبل الدعم
السريع وحتى بيت الضيافه مقر في هذه
المنطقه يفترض انها مقر اقامه الرجلين
برهان في هذه المنطقه باعتبار ان واحد
منهما رئيس مجلس السياده والاخر نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده
بالنسبه
للجرحى والضحايا سالم هل هناك اي احصائيه
حتى الان
لعدد المصابين وايضا اوضاعهم اذا كانت
حرجه ان كانت الاصابات طفيفه وبالنسبه
للضحايا
نعمل الاصابات
تتفاوت وليست هناك احصائيه دقيقه حتى هذه
اللحظه للنقط السودان المركزيه ذكرت بانها
عشرات ومئات ولم تحدد رقما حتى هذه اللحظه
لكن المؤكد هنا في منطقه بحري في منطقه
بحري بالقرب من المنطقه الاشتباك في منطقه
بحري ذهبنا في زياره نهار اليوم الى
مستشفى الدولي وهو في بحر لتفقد المصابين
ووجدنا الاحصائيه 25 اصابه ووفاه احد
الذين احضروا للمستشفى بعد محاوله الاطباء
في المستشفى هذه الحاله وكان اصابته وطلق
ناري في الظهر بقيه الحالات فيها حالات
حرجه حالتين تقريبا والحالات الاخرى
اصابات متفرقه بين
نيران مختلفه هذه الاصابات فيها 11 اصابه
كانت من داخل المنزل بقيه الاصابات كانت
خارج المنزل اي في الشوارع الاشتباكات
كانت عنيفه جدا وتم استخدام العديد من
الاسلحه في هذه المناطق بالقرب من المناطق
السكنيه التي يقطن فيها السكان ثلاث مناطق
سكنيه كبيره جدا في منطقه البحرين الشعبيه
وكذلك منطقه كوبر هذه المناطق تعرضت فيها
او كان فيها اشتباك عنيف مع لدوي طلقات
وكذلك القنابل وغير ذلك من الاسلحه والارض
وبعد ذلك كان هناك قصر بالطيران في هذه
المناطق شكرا لك حتى الان سالم دائما
سنعود اليك لتطلعنا على كل تطورات الحاصله
في اكد المتحدث العسكري باسم القوات
المسلحه المصريه غريب عبد الحافظ غريب
انهم يتابعون الاحداث الجاريه داخل
الاراضي السودانيه عن كثب مشيرا الى ان
التنسيق جاري مع الجهات المعنيه في
السودان لضمان تامين القوات المصريه
الموجوده هناك في اطار اجراء تدريبات
مشتركه مع نظرائهم في السودان
من جانبه اكد قائد قوات الدعم السريع
السودانيه للعربيه ان قوته ملتزمه بامن
وسلامه الجنود المصريين وانه سيتم اجلاؤهم
سريعا
ملتزمين بامن وسلامتهم الا الاشتباكات في
اشتباكات هنا وهناك بتجي علينا وهم
موجودين معانا لكن احنا في امنوا ملتزمين
تماما وهم في الحفظ
والصون ونحن اقرب
طريقه انه نحن نخليهم طواليتهم ان شاء
الله
في تصريحات للعربيه وصف الامين العام
المساعد لجامعه الدول العربيه حسام زكي
الوضع في السودان بالمؤسف للغايه معبرا عن
استعداد الجامعه العربيه لاجراء وساطه بين
الاطراف السودانيه لاستعاده الهدوء كما
دعا كافه الاطراف السودانيه لوقف التصعيد
فورا لافتا الى ان هناك صعوبه في التواصل
مع القيادات السودانيه المعنيه
في وقت سابق اليوم دع وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان الاشقاء في
السودان لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه وضبط
النفس واكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي في
سلسله تغريدات على تويتر الاطراف
السودانيه لتجنب التصعيد وتغليب مصلحه
شعبهم كما دعا الاطراف السودانيه الى
العوده للاتفاق الايطالي للتوصل لحل سياسي
لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار للبلاد
من الخرطوم ينضم اليه الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجيه الفريق دكتور جلال تاور كما
ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا دكتور يعقوب
عبد الكريم نورين استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
ومن القاهره معنا الصحفيه المختصه في
الشان الافريقي صباح موسى اهلا بكم ضيوفى
الكرام ابدا معك دكتور جلال هذه العمليات
او هذه العمليه العسكريه هي بين مكونين
عسكريين عسكريين ينتمون لنفس المؤسسه
العسكريه
هل من الممكن ان يكون رابح وخاسر في هذه
المعركه
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الصالح الطيبه والتحيه
لك ولكل المشاهدين
المعرفه نعم هي بين الجيش السوداني وهو
الجيش الاطول عمرا والاكثر خبره وبين قوات
الدعم السريع وهي القوات المنشيه حديثا من
داخل معسكرات الجيش السوداني وتدريباته
وعملياته كان قوات مسانده للجيش الان
اصبحت لها قانون خاص واعتبر القوات نظميه
يعني تعمل لاسناد القوات المسلحه وتقديم
العظماء كما كان ذلك ضروريا
هل يتم التعامل معها الان كقوات متمرده هل
يتم التعامل معها كاملشيات لانه هناك عده
اوصاف اليوم اطلقت على الدعم السريع
طبعا اولا الان صدر قرار رئيس مجلس
السياده بحل هذه القوات تماما وقبل صدور
ايضا للعربيه تحدثت دكتور الاستخبارات
تحدثت عن هذا الحال ولكن ايضا مصادر في
الجيش
السوداني تحدث للعربيه وقال بانه البرهان
لم يحل الدعم السريع حتى الان
والبيان المنشوره على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه كلها حتى من القياده العامه
يشير الى ان البرهان اصدر قرارا بحل
المليشي باعتبار قوه داله القوات الدعم
السريع باعتبارها هو متمرده وطبعا قبل
يعني الحل كان هنالك قرار صادر بانه يعتبر
متمرره غير مستجيبه للتعليمات والاعاد
وغير متعادله في الواجبات
المهام الموقره لها بموجب قانون الدعم
الشريعي والبيان الذي اصدر الناطق الرسمي
باسم القوات المسلحه حدد فيه غده النقاط
بموجبه هذه القوات يعني غير مستجيبه او
غير متعاونه مع القوات المسلحه ومهمتها
الاساسيه كانت تقديم لهذه القوات المسلحه
فهي الان عموما في يعني وصف معادي للقوات
المسلحه تتعاركات الالعاب مع القوات
المسلحه نعمل معرفه قد لا يكون فيها يعني
رابع او خاسر باعتبار ان الاثنين قوات
سودانيه تقاتل بعضها البعض بدلا من ان
تتعاون مهمتها ان تتعاون وتنجز مع بعض
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار يعني تغيير الامن
القومي السوداني اصبحت تقاتل بعد ما يهدد
الامن ليس السوداني فقط انما حتى الاقليمي
والدولي بهذه الاشتباكات التي ازعجت كل
العالم حضرتك
خبير امني هل الدعم السريع لديه من
الامكانيات والعتاد والاسلحه والذخيره
قادره على مواجهه الجيش السوداني الذي
يعني هو عمره اكثر من 100 سنه هذا الجيش
وخضع الكثير من الحروب
خضع الكثير من القلوب يعني مره بالكثير من
التغيرات وتطورات والتدريبات
والبروتوكولات مع القوات الشبيهه في دول
اخرى يعني هو ليس كدعم السريري اي حال من
الاحوال الدعم السريع قوات خفيفه سريعه
الحركه لها نشاط تستطيع الدخول في مناطق
معينه والخروج منها وقدمت مساعدات كبيره
جدا للقوات المسلحه عبال يعني الفترات
الماضيه خاصه في علاقه مع الحركاء الحركات
اما مثلا ان تهزم القوات المسلحه او تسيطر
عليها او ما الى ذلك فهذا امر ليس باليسير
باي حال من الاحوال يعني الفارغ الكبير ما
بين الاثنين بعدين خبره الاثنين ما بين
التعداد الاثنين تدريبات الاثنين تاهيل
الاثنين في المساله يعني ليست هنالك يعني
نقطه ممكن للمقارنه بين الاثنين باي حال
من الاحوال
الدعم السريع هناك خبر عاجل على شاشه
العربيه تعلن في بيان سيطرتها على القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه ماذا يعني ذلك
وكثير من البيانات التي تصدر بهذا اليوم
يعني لا يؤخذ بها
سودانيه وهذا ادى الى كثير من التعظيم لكن
بعد ذلك صدر بيان من القوات المسلحه من
الناطق الرسمي انه الاوضاع تحت السيطره
تماما بما في ذلك المطار مقر سكن بيت
الضيافه السكن رئيس البرهان والقياده
العامه ايضا الجيش السوداني الان ينفي
سيطره الدعم السريع على منطقه التصنيع
الحربي اذا الجيش السوداني ينفي سيطره
الدعم السريع على منطقه التصنيع الحربي
اسمح لي ان اذهب ايضا الان الى الدكتور
يعقوب عبد الكريم نورين استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه دكتور يعقوب اهلا بك معنا في ظل
هذا التصعيد المسار السياسي ما هو مصيره
اولا نحن تحياتي لك وللساده المشاهدين
ونتاسف لما حدث صراحه يعني هذا العمل عمل
يعني لا يشبه السودانيين وعمل كانت الناس
كلهم كانوا متوقعين انه يتم اللقاء بين
المسجلين القائد الجيش وقائد الدعم
السريعه صباح اليوم ولكن هنالك من لا يريد
بهذا السودان الاستقرار وقد حذرنا نحن
مرارا وتكرارا انه هنالك من يحاول ان
يزعزع هذا الامر
الاسلاميين الان الفيديوهات منتشره الان
الاسلاميين هم بجانب بيسلحوا في الناس
بيوزعوا في الكاكي وبيعملوا كل الاشياء
القبيحه عشان يعني هم ما حيقدروا يلقوا
وطن يحكموه لانه الفتنه هذه سوف تقضي على
الاخضر والي بغض النظر الذي اطلع الرصاص
الاولى ولكن نحن بنتكلم عن وطنه الوطن
مهمتنا حتى هنالك معلومات تشير الى ان
البرهان لم يكن يعلم بتحرك تلك القوه التي
في المدينه الرياضيه
وبالتالي على انه هنالك الطرف الثالث وهو
الذي لا يريد للعمليه سي ان تمضي ولا يريد
للشعب السوداني ان يستغل على تحول ديم
وغرافي لسانهم الحكم هو الذي طلب سلطتهم
والجيش هو الذي سلم سلطتهم
الا في السودان دكتور يعقوب اذا حضرتك
تتحدث ان هناك طرف ثالث لماذا الطرفان اي
القوات القوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني لماذا لا يتوقف عن هذا التحارب
هما الطرفان الذي الذين يتحاربان الان
نعم هما الطرفان الذين يتحاربون دي حقيقه
ولكن من الذي اشعل الفتنه نحن نتحدث عن من
الذي اشعل الفتنه قد اتفق غاده الجيش
وغاده الدعم السريع على
الخروج ولكن ما الذي حدث طوالي تمت شيطنه
القوى السياسيه وان هذا الاتفاق جاء من
الدول الاجنبيه وكذا وتحركت العالميه
للفلوس بعد الذين وجدوا البراهمه الانقلاب
25 اكتوبر وبالتالي كانت العمليه مزعجه
جدا بالنسبه للناس طب كيف سيؤثر على
الاتفاق على الاطار الاتفاق الان هذا
الاتفاق الايطالي كيف سيؤثر هذه الا تعوق
العمليه السياسيه ما يجري الان المساله
الان المساله الان اصبحت حرب حرب يعني
عارفين يعني شو معنى حرب الحربي معروفه
الحرب ما معروفه النتائج يحصل شنو ولا
الان السياسيين كلهم حتى اذا اراد ان
يتوسط او يحل المشكله كيفيه هذا التوسط
وبالتالي يمشي يتحركوا عشان يوصلوا الناس
يقعدوا معاهم دواسه
ولكن هنالك من لا يريد للسودان استقرار
ان يستمر
يجب ان يعود الى الحكم ويعود عبر الجيش
ويعود عبر الناس الموجودين داخل الجيش من
الخلود
بالمصيبه الكبيره
على كل حال ساعود اليك دكتور يعقوب ساعود
اليك ولكن دعني الان اذهب الى القاهره
تنضم الينا الصحفيه المختصه في الشان
الافريقي صباح موسى سيده صباح اهلا بك
معنا بالنسبه لما يجري الان من تصعيد في
السودان هل من الممكن ان يكون المسار
السياسي او التفاوض خاصه في ظل هذا
التصعيد بالبيانات بانه لا حوار بين بعضهم
هم يرفضون الحوار وبان هذه المعركه ستستمر
في البدايه تحياتي لك وتحياتي لضيوفك
للساده المشاهدين بالتاكيد ما حدث اليوم
في الخرطوم من صراع ومواجهات عسكريه من
قوات القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع بالتاكيد سيوقف استمرار
العمليه السياسيه في السودان حتى يعني
تتضح الرؤيه على الارض وهل هذا الصراع من
الممكن ان يتوقف في المستقبل القريب ام لا
انا تقديري ان الصراع طالما الطلقه الاولى
كما يطلقون عليها انطلقت صباح اليوم اعتقد
ان الامور من الصعوبه ان تعود الى طاوله
حوار حتى على مستوى المدنيين في هذا
التوقيت في السودان لابد من حسم المعركه
اولا وهذا حديث الجيش السوداني بمعنى اننا
لن نعود الى حوار الا بعد حسم التفلتات
الدعم السريعه وبالتالي
البيانات التي تصدر
على مدار الساعه من الخرطوم من قبل الدعم
السريع الذي يتفوق في نظري في الحرب
الاعلاميه الموجوده في الخرطوم الان هو
يطلق بيانات الجيش السوداني يهرول لكي
ينفيها لم يكن هو
المبادر في هذه البيانات ليطمئن الشارع
السوداني طبعا بالتاكيد بالدعم السريع نعم
هو يعني يسيطر على
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في السودان ولكن هذه
السيطره اتت من ان الدعم السريع كان يقوم
بحراسه هذا المبنى ولو كان يمثل خطوره هذا
الحصار لشاهدنا قوات الدعم السريع تستغل
هذه الاله الخطيره في هذه الحرب كان من
الممكن ان تخرج بيانات الدعم السريع من
الاذاعه والتلفزيون السودانيه لكن حتى
اللحظه منذ صباح اليوم لم يخرج اي بيان
البيانات تخرج من العربيه والقنوات
العربيه المختلفه ولم تخرج من الاذاعه
والتلفزيون السودانيه قبل قليل انت عرضتي
تقارير للبرهان وهو يسير في الشوارع وهذه
لطمانه الجمهور بان القوات اسم المسلحه
وتسيطر على الاوضاع يعني بيانات ده يؤكد
ان بيانات الدعم السريع التي تنطلق بهذه
الحته باننا استولينا على يعني سلاح
المهندسين وعلى استولينا على المطارات
وعلى كل هذا من الصباح الباكر حرب اعلاميه
شرسه في
يعني في فوضى غير محسوبه في السودان وفي
غير تاكيد لكن بهدوء شديد الجيش السوداني
ينفي وينفي لكن انا في تقدير المعركه
ستمتد والكلام عن اي حديث في سياسي او
مدني في هذا التوقيت اعتقد انه من الصعوبه
فاذا صباح ساعود اليك والى ضيوف الكرام
ولكن سنتوقف مع بعض التطورات الميدانيه
حيث كشفت مصادر عسكريه لقناه العربيه بان
الجيش السوداني تمكن من ضرب اغلب مراكز
التواصل للدعم السريع والسيطره على اغلب
المرافق في مطار مروي كما اكدت ان الجيش
السوداني يواصل التقدم نحو مراكز الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم وتمكن من السيطره على
اجواء البلاد بالكامل واشارت الى ان الجيش
السوداني يحاول خلالها عزل الدعم السريع
تقليل الخسائر المدنيه
ويتوقع فرض سيطرته الكامله بحلول فجر
اليوم
[موسيقى]
يمكن
مبروك والله مبروك
مبروك الله مبروك والله
مبروك والله
هذا وتوقف البث المباشر للاحداثي
للتلفزيون السودانيه الرسمي بعد ان سمع
صوت اطلاق نار على الهواء فيما اكدت مصادر
ان قوات الدعم السريه تمكنت من السيطره
على مقره في الخرطوم فيما استعاد الجيش
السيطره على محيط المبنى
الا اننا في داخل الهيئه العامه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون في التلفزيون السودان وفي
الاذاعه السودانيه الان الاحوال هادئه
ونحاول ان نتواصل مع بعض المحللين لنقف
على ابعاد ما يحدث الان وما نستمع
من جانبه اكد رئيس الوزراء السودانيه
السابق عبد الله حمدوك بان الحل السلمي في
البلاد لا يزال ممكن ان حيث دعا الاطراف
العسكريه الى المتحاربه طبعا الى وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار والجلوس على طاوله الحوار
يجب ان يتوقف الرصاص فورا ويجب ان يحكم
صوت العقل فالخساره ستكون من نصيب الجميع
ولا يوجد منتصر على جثث شعبه رساله
الثانيه للشعب السوداني بان يزداد تماسكا
وان يكون تلاحم مكونات المجتمع وخطاب رفض
الاحتراب والسعيد وان لا يتم السماح لصوت
اذكى الحرب بالسيطره رساله الثالثه
للمجتمع الاقليمي والدولي ومحبي السلام
العالمي بان يقوموا بواجبهم في الحل
وتهدئه الاطراف المتقاتله فالحرب في
السودان تعني الحرب في الاقليم ولا يزال
الحل السلمي ممكنا
[موسيقى]
ما كان ام الصراعا على السلطه بين مكونين
عسكري ومدني اليوم نزاعا على السلطه نفسها
بين جنرلين نسف مقوله قوه واحده على قلب
رجل واحد التي رددها سابقا رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
فحمتي لم يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في
الدوله او النائب نتابع
امبراطوريتان عسكريتان قامتا على انقاض
حكم البشير رجل الحكم العسكري في السودان
نفايا مرارا وجود اي خلاف بينهما وحجم
التراشق الكلامي في خانه حرب زائفه ابتدعت
اعلاميا بهدف خرق الصف الواحد الا انه
منزلق للمواجهه المسلحه
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد القوات البريه في
عهد البشير صار قائدا للجيش النظامي فيما
اسس الثاني اي محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحمدتي قوات الدعم السريع معتمدا
عالميليشيا خاضت حربا داميه في دارفور
لكنه لم يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في
الدوله او النائب
تهديد فعلي شكله احمدتي للبرهان معززا
امبراطوريته بجيش خاص قوامه 100 الف عنصر
اي ما يوازي تقريبا حجم قوات الجيش
السوداني فضلا عن تكسب اقتصادي نتج عن عقد
صفقات مع شركات دوليه
حملتي راى في الاتفاق الايطالي اداه
للمحافظه على مكتسباته لكن التوقيع فشل
مرتين بسبب خلافات حول دمج قوه الدعم
السريع في الجيش ومداه الزمني ووضعيه
قياده القوات ففي حين اراد البرهان اتمام
الدمجي وفقا لقواعد الجيش وانظمته تمسك
احمدتي باعاده هيكله قياده الجيش العليا
اولا حتى يكون جزءا منها قبل دمج قواته
وتقليص نفوذه
لا يزال ما تحبه
بالكذب ما بنلتقي قدام احسن نمشي
قضايا خلافيه اخرى شقت طريقها الى
المنظومه الامنيه مثل اصلاح الجيش وابعاد
انصار النظام السابق عنه كما مثلت اداره
الملفات الخارجيه ونسج نائب البرهان
لعلاقات عابره للحدود تحديا كبيرا
للجانبين فحمل تيم من قبل الجيش بخلق
علاقات دبلوماسيه موازيه للدوله
اعود الى ضيوف من الخرطوم الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجيه الفريق الدكتور جلال تاور
ومن الخرطوم ايضا معنا دكتور يعقوب عبد
الكريم نورين استاذ العلاقات الدوليه ومن
القاهره انضمت الينا الصحفيه المختصه في
الشان الافريقي صباح موسى دكتور اعود اليك
دكتور تاور الى اي حد موضوع توقع فرد
سيطره الجيش السوداني على الامر وعلى
السودان من جديد فجر اليوم
في الجيش او رئاسه الارقام لانها حتى
ان شاء الله ستكون قد حصلت معاركها مع
الدعم السريع واعاده الامور الى نصابه
وتوقفت المعارك في كل ارحال البلاد ونسال
الله ان يوفقك
قبل قليل كان يتحدث ويقول لانه قدام
القياده العامه
وانه حتى الصباح
وسيحقق يعني ما وعد به ويستولى على
المقرات الجيش المتبقي يعني هنالك ما زال
يعني تحنوا العراق وقتال مدى في مدى الليل
لكن البيان الرسم هو المتوقع الصغير
الامور باذنه تعالى حتى غير الغد او حتى
لو استمرت حتى الناس يعني يعملون ان تنتهي
هذه المعارك باسرع ما يمكن ان يتوقف نزيف
الدم على كل حال الجيش السوداني الان
دكتور يقول بانه رئيس دائره الاستخبارات
بالدعم السريع يعلن انضمامه للجيش اذا حسب
الجيش السوداني رئيس دائره الاستخبارات
بالدعم السريع يعلن انضمامه للجيش هل من
الممكن ان تبدا عمليه انشقاقات من الدعم
السريع للدخول الى الجيش او بالتالي
بالعكس مثلا ايضا افراد تخرج من الجيش
وتذهب للدعم السريع هل نتوقع هذا
السيناريو عمليه الانشغه منذ النهار منذ
نهار اليوم يعني كثير من الوحدات الدعم
السريعه في انضمامه بالكامل في الولايات
بذات للقوات المسلحه مسلمه حدث النيل
الابيض في القضارف في بورسودان في بورستي
في كادولي كل هذه المناطق يعني اعلنت
الانضمام هذه القوات المسلحه وقلها كانت
تتبع للقوات الدعم فضلا عن المنتدبين بعد
افراد المسلحه ضباط الى الاخير كانوا يعني
منتدرين للعمل ضمن قوات الدعم السريعه
اليوم اعلن رجوع لاعداداتهم في شقاقهم من
الدعم السريع فيعني عامه الانشغال هذه
مستمره ولا تتوقف الدعم السريع نفسه قال
ان
المفتش العرض يعمل مع الدعم الشريحه
المفتش العاب للقوات المسلحه ولكن دكتور
امام مدى خطوره هذا التصعيد بين مكونين
داخل اهم مؤسسه امنيه في السودان وخاصه
بانه الوضع في السودان يعني ليس مستتبا
هناك اوضاع صعبه اقتصاديه امنيه
طبعا الاشكال ليس في الانشقاقات وتاثيرها
على الامن انما الاشكال في الخلاف الذي
قال الى هذه المعارك واذا هذا الصراع نفسه
يعني القوات المسلحه كانت موجوده بانشقاق
او بدون شراء والدعم كان موجود بانشراقه
لكن الاشكال في يعني
المواجهه المسلح التي
حصل ينفيان علمهما او توقعون على هذه
الحادثه البرهان يقول حتى الساعه الثالثه
صباح اليوم هو فوج بقوات من الدعم
لانه هو حتى يعني ليل الامس بعد الساعه
12:00 بالليل كان متوقع ان يجلس مع
البرهان حسب الوصفات التي تمت
خطرا ان يكون هناك هذه الثغره الامنيه
يعني تنشب حرب من دون علم قادتها هل هذا
يعقل وهو طبعا اللي هو طبعا خطيره جدا جدا
لكن هذا ما ورد على لسان الرجلين اللذان
يقودان هذه المعركه الان هذا يقود من جانب
القوات المسلحه وهذا يعود من جانب الدعم
يمشي علمه او انه هو الذي بادر بهذا
الهجوم الجيش يمشي والدعم السريع ينفي دي
مشكله مهمه جدا ومشكله يعني اساسيه لكن
لابد من تجاوزها الان والمرور عليه
بمحاوله يعني باسرع ما يمكن نزع الفتيل
الازمه نعم ممكن نذهب الان الى دكتور
يعقوب دكتور يعقوب هل الحل السياسي
من خلال سيكون من خلال المبادرات من
الاحزاب السياسيه والاطراف السياسيه
السودانيه ام هذا لن يكفي وانما سيكون
هناك ايضا مبادرات خارجيه ان كان اقليميه
عربيه او دوليه
والله العظيم
عندها وقعها والعالميه والدوليه عندها
وقعه يعني ودي مهم جدا بعدين يعني
قد كلام
الان
في البدايه لانه ممكن زول يكون قاعد ما
عارف القصه
من الذي حرك القوات
المحاصي هناك حرك القوات الجهه الاخرى دي
كلها يعني القضيه دي اشكاليه كبيره
ومحليه
نجح
الموضوع هو صاد دوليه من قوه عندها وزنها
وعندها ضمانات وتعرف تاخذ الضمانات
الانفراض العقد في السودان انفراط العقد
في السودان يؤثر قلت لك على كل دول
الاقليم يعني اصلا ليبيا جدا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ست صباح الى اي حد المبادرات
الاقليميه والعربيه والدوليه هي الوحيده
القادره الان على وقف هذا العنف وهذا
التصعيد بين الاطراف العسكريه في السودان
من الممكن بالفعل ان يكون هناك مبادرات
وخصوصا المبادرات الاقليميه لرايب هذا
الصدع الخطير في الخرطوم من المعلوم ان
قوات الدعم السريع لديها قوات يعني تدعمها
بشكل مباشر في الاقليم ايضا الجيش
السوداني لديه قوات تدعمه بشكل مباشر في
الاقليم صحيح ان الموضوع من الصعوبه لان
هذه القوه الاقليميه والدوليه تدخلت على
مدى سنوات
بالغت الاربع سنوات لتقريب وجهات النظر
بين مدنيين اعتقد انه من الصعوبه سيكون
وفشل بالتاكيد مع الطلقه الاولى صباح
اليوم اعتقد انه من الصعوبه في هذا
التوقيت حتى الحديث عن مبادرات اقليميه كل
طرف
وداعميها الاقليميين والدوليين اعتقد انهم
يريدوا ان يحسموا الموت المعركه اولا قبل
لا مكان للمسار السياسي
ولا للتفاوض الا بحسم عسكري
اعتقد ان الامور تتجه لهذا الاتجاه لابد
من حسم عسكري سواء من الطرفين كل طرف
يحاول الان ان يصدر وبخصوص الدعم السريع
هي تحاول ان تصدر انها تسيطر على المقرات
وانها هي الفائزه حتى اللحظه ولكن اعتقد
ان هذا الحديث لا يمكن ان يكون يعني
جنرال الجيش السوداني لا يمكن ان تقبل
بمثل هذا الحديث حتى لو كان في رجعه
للحوار بالتاكيد حديث حتى القائد قوات
الدعم السريع صباح اليوم وهو يتحدث عن
قائد القوات المسلحه بانه مجرم وانه سوف
يقدمه للعداله هذا الحديث من الصعوبه
اعتقد انه صعب ان يجلس الرجلان وانت
تعلمين ان المعركه هي معركه قيادات الان
المعركه قياده الدعم السريع وقياده القوات
المسلحه من الصعوبه ان يتم الجلوس بعد هذه
الاوصاف من التي وصف فيها قائد الدعم
السريع قائد الجيش السوداني اعتقد ان حتى
لو تم حل حل قوات الدعم السريع اعتقد ان
هذا القرار بعد ذلك لا اعتقد انه له اي
تاثير على الارض لان قوه الدعم السريع
قوات ليست نظاميه ليست كقوات العمليات
التي تم حلها من قبل ليست كقوات منتظمه
داخل الجيش السوداني باعتبار ان قرار الحل
يستوجب يعني يعني الانصياع للاوامر قوه
الدعم السريع ولا اهل الاول والاخير لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع وبالتالي مثل هذه
القرارات على ارض الواقع اعتقد انها ليس
لها مصير واعتقد ان
عمليه السودان العمليه العسكريه الان هي
اتخذت منحه شخصي بحث وستاخذها الى النهايه
ولا اعتقد ان الحوار سيكون قريبا حتى لو
فرض ان هناك تدخلات اقليميه ودوليه لكن في
تقدير الشخصي في المستقبل القريب طاوله
الحوار غير وارده في الخرطوم الان شكرا لك
من القاهره الصحفيه المختصه في الشان
الافريقيه صباح موسى على المشاركه معنا
وابقى مع ضيوفي من الخرطوم اعود اليك
دكتور جلال بعد يعني كما ذكرت الان ست
صباح موسى بعد هذه التوصيفات للاطراف
لبعضها البعض اني اصبحت الامور شخصيه الى
اي مدى حتى لو توقفت هذه الحرب او هذه
الاشتباكات وهذا العنف داخل السودان ستعود
الامور كما كانت عليه بين هاتين الشخصيتين
العسكريتين سيد حميتي وسيد عبد الفتاح
البرهان
مؤكد انه
اللغه التي استخدمت في الامن الاخيره يعني
كانت لا تتناسب مع وضعيه الرجلين في قياده
هذه
القوات مثل هذا الوصف الذي يقوله اليوم
وهذا وهذا هو قبله كان عبد الرحيم يوسف
بانه جبان بنى سورا لنفسه ولا يهمه ما
يحدث
هذه يعني ليست من ضمن اللغه العسكريه او
لغه المخاطبه العسكريه التي تقوم على
الانضباط الكامل والاحترام ما بين الرتب
يعني حتى التشاور لابد ان يفضل تكون في
اللغه يعني محترمه بين الاثنين
لكن نعود الى المساله الاصليه لانه
القياده الجيش الان هي اصرت انها لا
تستجيب الى اي وساطه او مفاوضات ما لم
تحسن المعركه حسب النهايه
ما المقصود بحسم المعركه
الانتصار الكامل على القوات التي تتصفها
بالمتمرد يعني ازاله خطر هذا التمرد
وتحيده تماما من انه يكون قوه تنازع
القوات المسلحه مؤكد
توصف الان بانها متمرده لكن بعض قياداتها
المؤثرين الذين يقولون في هذه المرحله هم
الذين ينطبق عليهم هذا
الوصف
مباشره القوات المسلحه ولم تعترض القوات
المسلحه بها واعتبرتها جزء منها والان
ولكن دكتور يعني بعد كل هذه السنوات التي
حكمت فيها قوات الدعم السريعه هل من
السهوله ان يتم الاطاحه بها
باختصار لو سمحت
اي نعم الان ضمان المواجهه يعني وصلت حد
يعني كبرت القوات القوات الدعم السريع
خارجه عن دار الطور يعني مخالفه او ليست
مستجيبه لتعليمات
القياده العامه او لتعليمات القائد العام
وهو في نفسه في الفطور المدرعات قال فقدنا
السيطره على قوات الدعم السريع اذ انها لا
تستجيب للاوامر ونتعامل معها بالصبر
والحكمه ولكن يبدو ان الصبر النفس ثم
انزلغت الاوضاع الى ما هي عليه الان
اسمحوا لي ان تبقوا معي ولكن سنتابع ايضا
هذا التقرير عن الانتفاضه الشعبيه التي
اطاحت في ابريل عام 2019 بحكم عمر حسن
البشير بعد هذه الاطاحه بدا السودان مسيره
التحول الى الديمقراطيه لكن عراقيل مختلفه
وقفت في الطريق في ظل الصراع المحتدله على
السلطه
في هذا البلد نتابع
السودان رحله شاقه من البحث عن الحريه
والديمقراطيه حكايه طويله لم تكتب لها
نهايه سعيده حتى الان
الان كم من ذلك ان هذا البلد العربي
والافريقيه انزلق نحو القتال بدل لغه
السلام والحوار
التحول نحو الحكم المستقر مثل شعله امل
حين تمت الاطاحه بنظام البشير عقب انتفاضه
شعبيه في ربيع العام 2019 في اغسطس من
السنه ذاتها وافق الجيش على تقاسم السلطه
مع المدنيين ريثما يتم اجراء انتخابات لكن
الترتيب تعطل وسرعان من قلب على ما التزم
به الزي العسكري في السودان وكحال اغلب
بلدان الجنوب يشكل قوه مهيمنه منذ
استقلاله عام
1956 اذ خاض حروبا داخليه وقام بانقلابات
متكرره ولديه حيازات اقتصاديه ضخمه حظي
الجيش بدعم داخلي من فصائل متمرده استفادت
من اتفاق السلام في 2020 ومن المخضرمين في
حكومه البشير الذين عادوا الى الخدمه
المدنيه الصراع بين قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
الب به محمد حمدان دقلو يوازيه صراع اخر
مع المدنيين الذين يضغطون من اجل الرقابه
على الجيش ودمج قوات الدعم السريع شبه
العسكريه التي لها وضع قوي في الجيش
النظامي امر اخر يدخل في المعادله السودان
موجود في منطقه مضطربه يحدها البحر الاحمر
ومنطقه الساحل والقرن الافريقي استقطب
موقعه الاستراتيجي وثرواته الزراعيه قوى
مختلفه ما ادى الى تعقيد فرص نجاح
الانتقال وها هو الان في طريق حرب اهليه
ستعيده سنوات الى الوراء بلال الوجداني
العربيه
مجددا اعود الى ضيوف دكتور يعقوب عبد
الكريم نورين اعود اليك من قادر يعني الكل
حتى الان منذ الصباح حتى الان كل ضيوفنا
يستبعدون في هذا التوقيت اي حل سياسي او
اي افاق لمسار سياسي ولكن بالنهايه يجب ان
يكون هناك من مسار سياسي لوقف هذا التصعيد
من قادر على فعل ذلك هل الداخل السوداني
قادر ام يجب ان يكون هذا الحل اتيا من دول
عربيه اقليميه ودوليه
والله هو هو في كل الحالات الحل يجب ان
يصلوا مهما طالوا الحرب فمهما طال عمده
ومهما استمرت يجب ان يصلوا لحد والحل هو
المطلوب لانه في النهايه الخسران الوطني
خسران شعبه وبالتالي نحن الان بنفتكر انه
الوصول الى حل مهم جدا العوده لصوت العقل
مهمه جدا تحكيم صوت العقل مهم جدا ولكن
يجب ان يتنازل الناس لان الان اي شخص او
كل طرفه يحاول ان يثبت انه هو على حق وهذه
الامور لا تعود البلاد الى سلام والى
اطمئنان ولذلك نرى ان المبادرات الدوليه
والاقليميه والداخليه ايضا وحتى على مستوى
الوطن العربي الان يعني فقط طلعت يعني
ثلاثه او اربعه دول السعوديه قطر الامارات
يعني قالت انها قلقت بشان الاوضاع في
الداخل ولكن ليس هنالك
جهود حديثه لوقف هذا العنف
لعب مصري ايضا كذلك ومصر ايضا لها لكن نحن
داي
رين يكون شويه في تحرك جاد يعني نحن الان
جامعه الدول العربيه نحن من السودان من
الدول المؤسسه الدول العربيه لكن الاهتمام
بقضايا السودان عند جامعه الدول العربيه
كاقل مستوى له الان اضيف الى
[موسيقى]
هل المشكله كانت من البدايه بانه يتم
ترقيع اي مشكل حاصل في السودان ولا يتم حل
جذري لاي ازمه
الحلول الحلول الجذريه لا تاتي من ضربه
لازم الحلول تاتي تدريجيه كل امر شاي كحل
تدريجيا يعني انت ما بتخاوي
المشاكل عشان تقدر تجد لي احد جذري الجحال
الجزري ياتي بالقهر ياتي بالحرب الان
الحاصله للان لكن نحن دايرين تدرج في
الحلول لحد ما
وصلني
والسياسيه المحليه ايضا كلها اذا كان
عارضه او غير معارضه
ما هو
ثوره لانه في النهايه
الوطن
شكرا لك من الخرطوم دكتور يعقوب عبد
الكريم نورين استاذ العلاقات الدوليه كما
اشكر من ضيفنا ايضا من الخرطوم الخبير
الامني والاستراتيجي الفريق الدكتور جلال
تاور على المشاركه معنا في هذه التغطيه في
هذه الساعه من التغطيه المستمره على
العربيه طبعا هذه التغطيه مشاهدينا ستبقى
مستمره على العربيه ولكن الان انتقل الى
زميلتنا راويه عالميه لتستكمل ما او ابرز
هذه التطورات الحاصله على ارض السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات